speaking of call me by your name the
best film of that year
uh obviously like everyone i want to get
a sequel to it
and i know you guys want to make one but
i also think that one of the things
about that movie is you really
need like years to pass in real life
to almost make the movie the sequel
resonate because you need to have like
lines in your face
like i'm getting there
i get in there steve i'm aging like milk
in a warm car buddy
come on i haven't noticed that if i can
get all these grays in there
i i haven't noticed that but do you but
do you agree with that that like even
though everyone's talking about it
i think it needs like 10 years before
you know it needs room to breathe too i
mean so many people
are emotionally invested in the first
poem by your name that
if you release a second one now no
matter what i feel like you're just
setting yourself up for failure
uh if you give us time and you know i
mean like the like the story is supposed
to happen if you give us that time
and then we can come back you know when
i'm in my 40s
you know and timmy's 23
you know then we could do it again then
you know right
no i just think it's important people
talk about that that it's just not going
to work if you do it like next year
100 agree agreed